NIKHIL KOTHARI: Hello, and
welcome to Cloud OnAir,
live webinar from Google Cloud.
I'm Nikhil Kothari,
an engineering
lead on Google Cloud Platform,
leading the ML Engine Team.
We're hosting these live
webinars every Tuesday.
Throughout this talk, you
can enter your questions.
And my colleague,
Dinesh Kulkarni,
who's a project manager on the
team, will be able to answer.
We'll also take some live
Q&A at the end of this talk.
So with that, let's get
started with the presentation.
Machine learning is all
around us these days.
Data scientists
and developers are
doing some really creative
things with their data
and powering some really
interesting machine learning
use cases.
One way to look at
machine learning
is through the lens
of the data that you
might use for your problem.
And this data might be
unstructured data, like images,
or it might be the more
familiar, structured, tabular
data.
And new and upcoming is also
time series and sequential
data.
Another way to look
at machine learning
is the business problems
that you might tackle.
And these might range from
perception and understanding
of all of this content,
to powering search,
to doing things
like recommendation,
as well as estimation of price
and risk in various businesses,
or things like
anomaly detection,
fraud detection, and so on.
Cloud ML Engine allows you to
tackle your machine learning
use cases with your data.
ML Engine in a nutshell is
about TensorFlow as a service.
It allows you to do training
and prediction, which
are the two most important
aspects of machine learning.
As a managed
service, it provides
APIs for these two
building blocks, training
and prediction, and allows
you to bring your data
and your models to the problem.
Taking a deeper
slightly deeper look
at these two parts
of the product,
training is all about bringing
to you the capabilities
to build your best model
at the best performance.
Using TensorFlow, you
can avail yourself
of scalable and
distributed training
that scales to the
largest of data sets.
You can use
accelerators like GPUs,
and soon, TPUs, to get the
best performance and quicker
turnaround time for
your experiments.
And then we also
offer capabilities
like HyperTune, which is
a hyper-parameter tuning
capability to allow you to find
and optimize your parameter
space for your best model.
The training API takes care
of all the infrastructure,
whether it's compute resources
or things like your jobs,
as well as the software stack
in terms of all the packages
and drivers and environment
needed for doing training.
On the prediction side,
once you have a model,
it's about bringing to you
the best production experience
without having you to
take on all the developer
operations in hosting and
serving models online.
It starts with model
management, which
allows you to bring
in models, deploy them
along with different
versions of your models.
And it constructs
an HTTP endpoint
that you can use
to connect securely
to your model and issue
requests and responses
to get predictions.
You can also use these models
in batch processing pipelines
using batch prediction.
I'll touch on a few of these in
the demo as we switch to that.
I'll be demoing a
very high-level view
of ML Engine using Jupyter
Notebooks, using a product
called Cloud Datalab.
So this is Cloud Datalab.
I've already opened
it up, and I've
got a variety of notebooks.
Like any ML problem,
it starts with data.
It starts with
understanding your data.
And the notebook format
allows you to very quickly get
a sense of your data.
In this particular
case, I'm going
to be using the New
York taxi fare data
set, which contains data
about different taxi rides--
their pick-up points, and
drop-off off points, and fares.
And what we're going
to do is build a model
to predict the fare.
And all this data
is in BigQuery.
So the first thing you
might do is actually
understanding your data.
And this involves first
looking at the schema, which
you can see using these tools
that we have in Datalab--
things like %bq to work
with BitQuery APIs.
So I can get a
sense of my schema.
I can also get a
sense of my data.
So this thing here has--
it's a fairly large data set.
So clearly, I'm also going
to be doing some sampling
to be able to work with
it in an interactive way.
Here's a quick
query that pulls out
locations from this data set.
And for every 10,000 rows,
it pulls out a data point.
So that's my simple sampling.
And then I can go
ahead and plot it.
And I get a fairly
uninteresting plot.
But it's actually interesting.
A bunch of data points are at
the 0 comma 0-- lat/long 0.
So clearly, there's some
data cleanup to be also done,
and filtering.
And so what I can do from what--
I know that this
is about New York.
And so I can sort of bound
the lat/long pairs to New York
and filter out all the data
that falls out of that.
And once I've done that
with a simple WHERE
clause that filters
data to New York,
I can re-execute this query.
I can execute that SQL.
It executes in BigQuery.
I retrieve that as
a pandas DataFrame.
Many of you are probably
familiar with pandas.
And then I can very
easily plot it.
And those who are familiar with
the geography around New York
probably can recognize this.
This sort of roughly
outlines Manhattan.
And you can sort of
see Central Park.
And that's where most
of the taxi rides
are in this data set.
So that gives you a quick sense
of how I can use the notebook
to understand my data and to
know what sort of preprocessing
I might need to do.
I can also go ahead
and build features.
Like, for example, I can use
the pick-up date and time
to construct two
features-- day of the week
and hour of the day.
And these are much
more interesting
from a machine
learning point of view
to understand and generalize
across different rides.
Once again, I can execute the
query and get a data frame.
I can get a preview of the
data in that data frame.
I can also get some
basic statistics,
like, for example, the
count of rows I got,
a number of unique values.
So this here, I see I have
seven unique days, which is--
I expect that.
I can also see minimum
and maximum values,
mean, those types of things.
I can also do simple things
like understand the correlation
between fare amount, which
is the column that I'm
going to predict, with other
columns, for example, distance.
And as you can see, it's highly
correlated with distance--
again, something
that we would expect,
but good to validate from does
the data match the domain?
So with that, my
next step is going
to be around data preparation.
And this is about taking your
data, producing sample data
sets, as well as producing
training data and evaluation
data.
So again, I'm using BigQuery.
And it's a similar
query, where I'm
picking out the features
that I want, filtering out
all of the noise--
the location, as well as making
sure these were valid rides.
And then I'm going ahead
and producing two data sets.
So here's my data set that
produces the evaluation set.
And here's my data set that
produces the training data set.
I'm going to go ahead and
execute these and export them
as a CSV file.
Once these are in CSV file
in Google Cloud Storage,
I can then use them in
my machine learning job.
And as a preview,
I can also look at,
once I've executed
this, here's the couple
of files that were
produced in my data set.
And here's a preview of
the content inside that.
Basically, it's the
fare and a whole bunch
of features that are going to
be used to predict that fare.
This is just a good way to
get a sense of your data
before you start
building a model.
It's also good to make sure
your training and evaluation
data are built out of the same
query so that they're in sync.
So let's look at going
into building a model.
There's traditional
models, like linear models.
And these fall into a
category called wide models.
There's the new up-and-coming
neural networks,
deep neural networks,
which are also
quite interesting
in the sense of they
are able to infer and learn
about the relationship
between your features.
And then there's a category
that combines the best of both.
And they're called
wide and deep models.
And that's what we're
going to go build today.
The inputs for this
particular model
are going to be the
pick-up and drop-off
locations, the timestamp,
and the number of passengers.
Think about this as the
types of information
you would have when trying to
estimate a fare for a ride that
hasn't happened yet.
So here's my TensorFlow code.
I have this already in
the interest of time.
TensorFlow offers
a high-level API
called estimators, which
provide all the necessary logic
to build TensorFlow models
based on a given set of features
and set of hyper-parameters.
So what I have here is I'm
building a DNN-linear combined
regressor-- that's the
wide and deep model--
for doing regression.
I'm predicting a price, which
is a continuous function.
And so that's a
regression model.
And I'm providing it a
set of linear features
and a set of deep features.
And then here's my hidden units,
which is the number of layers.
And that's a
hyper-parameter to my model.
Here's my columns.
I have my locations, day of
the week, hour of the day,
passenger count.
And then my deep columns are,
again, the similar columns.
And the deep part
of this model is
going to learn the relationships
between these features.
I can also add
features that weren't
in my original data set but
synthesized from my data
using TensorFlow.
So, for example, I'm
computing the distance
between the pick-up and
drop-off points right
in the TensorFlow model.
And so this logic will
run both during training
as well as in prediction
once this model is ready.
So once I have my
TensorFlow code,
it's actually fairly
straightforward
to start using it.
Most developer
workflows are going
to involve using
your sample data,
and training locally, and
making sure your model generally
works.
So what I have here is
a gcloud command, gcloud
ml-engine local train, where
I point it at my Python code
that I was just showing, along
with references to my data.
So I'm using my sample
data set as well as
the number of steps I want
to perform training over.
I've already run this.
But what I will go
ahead and do is launch.
Actually, I guess
I haven't run this.
So I will go ahead and run this.
So while this is running, I can
start bringing up TensorBoard.
And we can look at what happens
as the training progresses.
So you'll see that this is--
the training process
is working well.
It's bringing up some data.
We can also look at the graph.
This is the graph of the model
that the estimator built.
It has the DNN, the Deep
Neural Network part,
as well as the
linear model part.
Let's refresh this.
And you can see that
as training proceeds,
it will incrementally
improve the model over time.
And you can see, it's live.
It's updating.
And we've set this to
train over 5,000 steps.
It's gone about a
third of the way.
So we'll let this
complete in a second.
So meanwhile, we'll go
back to this notebook.
And we'll prepare some sample
data that we'll predict over.
And this is basically
the types of instances
that will be used once
the model is ready.
Let's see if it's done.
Now, the model that's
going to be produced here
is actually going to be
fairly simplistic as well
as not very predictive,
because I'm only
using a very small
subset of the data.
So in the interest
of time, I'm going
to go ahead and switch
over to the next step
while this is still running,
which is training on the cloud.
Now, that's where ML Engine
shows up and helps you actually
use much more of your
data in the cloud.
So once again, it's the
same familiar command.
I'm using gcloud
ml-engine jobs submit
and submitting a training job.
And here, many of
the parameters are
the same as the
local case, where I'm
pointing it at my Python code.
But now, in the
context of Cloud,
I'm also telling it where
in Cloud, which region--
for example, US Central--
which directory to
put the outputs into,
which is going to be a
Google Cloud Storage bucket.
And then I'm also going
to pick a scale tier.
And here, I've picked a
scale tier called basic,
which is basically a
single, no-training job.
And once I execute that,
this job will get submitted.
I can go to the
console and open up--
so I've already run this job.
You can see, the
console shows this job.
You can also look at the
logs for this particular job.
And this shows all of the logs,
including things like the loss
and the global steps as
the training progressed,
all outputted in a
log for you to be
able to see what happened.
Like the local case, I can
also bring up TensorBoard
and open that.
And this particular job
is already completed.
So you can see,
this particular job
has made it all the way through.
I can see the loss,
the global steps
all progressed to
the 5,000 steps
that I chose for this
Cloud job as well.
So that's great.
I can go ahead and also use
GPUs on the cloud very easily.
So this is the same job.
All I did was change scale
tier from basic to basic GPU.
And now I have a single
no-training job using GPUs
without having to
worry about setting up
GPUs or software
associated with GPUs.
And I can do the same thing.
It'll launch a job.
I can go to the console, look
at logs, look at TensorBoard.
More interesting in
this particular example
is distributor training.
So very similar, again,
all I needed to do
was change the scale tier
from basic to standard.
And now this gives me a
configuration, a cluster,
where I have a master node that
runs training and evaluation,
a set of workers, and a
set of parameter servers
that share a state
for the whole job.
And what this thing
does is, it allows
me to use a lot more of
my data and put a lot more
compute power behind it.
So let me open up a
TensorBoard for this.
So it's getting
the same set of--
similar set of charts.
But an interesting
thing to look at here
is global steps per second.
And what I'm seeing is something
like 55 steps per second.
Worse is, say, the
other job, where
I had a single node, where
I was getting about 14.
And so this is sort
of the power of Cloud,
where I was able to spin
up a cluster very quickly
and easily for my job and be
able to increase the throughput
at which my training happens.
So now, let's also look
at what this job produced.
As output, all of
the model files
were produced into
Google Cloud Storage.
So this is where this particular
job saved all the outputs.
I have my checkpoints, which are
intermediate stages of my model
as the training is progressing.
In case the job needs
to recover and restart,
it can pick up from the
last known checkpoint.
It also produces
all of the events.
These summary files are the ones
that TensorBoard visualizes.
These contain a log of all of
the metrics that were produced.
But most importantly, you
have the model itself.
So here is my saved model
and the set of variables
that were saved along with it.
These variables are the
learned weights, so all
of the weights of the
linear parts of the model
as well as the deep
parts of the model.
And this is what I will
use to perform predictions.
So in order to
perform predictions,
I'll go ahead and actually
deploy this model.
So I'm going to go ahead and
refer to that model using
that path in Cloud Storage where
the saved model was located.
And I'm going to
issue two commands.
ml-engine models
create-- this creates
a new model called "taxifare."
And then I could
go ahead and deploy
a particular version of the
model using what I just saved.
And if I go to my console--
I've already gone ahead
and saved this out.
So here's my taxifare model.
And it has a v1 model that
I've already gone ahead
and deployed.
Once I have a model deployed,
I'm ready to use it.
Here's a little
bit of Python code
to issue a HTTP request
to this particular model.
So here's where you can see--
here's the URL for
this particular model.
As a developer, I
did not have to write
any of the associated
HTTP application code.
All I did was deploy
the model that
was produced from my training.
And I can go ahead and construct
an instance with the features
that I want to predict
over, issue the response--
issue the request, and
receive a response.
And the response is, as you
might expect, the prediction.
And in this
particular case, it's
predicting that the
fare is going to be $11.
So as you can see,
I went very quickly
from using TensorFlow, training
a model locally, building
and training a model locally.
With a single
configuration change,
I was able to train it on Cloud.
Without having to worry about
compute VMs and resources
or job management, I was able
to go from CPU-only training
to GPUs as well as from single
node to distributed training.
And then finally, once
I have a model ready,
I can go ahead and deploy it
as a version and try it out.
And this API is something that I
could bring into my application
and embed it in my
app to be able to use
this model in production.
So that was a very
quick overview
of ML Engine in action.
ML Engine is part of a
much larger set of products
that are geared
around helping you
with your entire
end-to-end ML workflow.
And this ranges
from data injection,
bringing new data into Cloud,
to managing and storing it--
things like Google Cloud
Storage as well as BigQuery--
exploration-- Datalab--
you saw that--
as well as the power
of SQL and BigQuery.
And then you saw ML Engine
doing the modeling work.
And then beyond this sort of
single development workflow,
we also have products to
allow you to build pipelines
that allow you to construct
models over data as it arrives
or over time and updating your
models in an automated way.
And so this is sort of
from data, to exploration,
to training, to production.
So with that, to recap,
we have TensorFlow, which
you can find on tensorflow.org.
This is Google's machine
learning runtime,
with the latest
and greatest APIs.
You can use ML Engine to
train and predict at scale.
And you can use familiar
Jupyter Notebooks
using Cloud Datalab for
your data science workflows.
We're going to switch
over to questions.
We're going to
take a quick break
and then come back to live Q&A.
We'll be back in less than a
minute
All right.
We're back with questions
from the audience.
This is great to
see, that people
have provided their questions.
And I'm happy to take
more questions as we go
along answering the first few.
"Since the model is
as good as the data,
how do I tag a model with the
specific versions of data?"
So yes, indeed, machine
learning is largely--
how good your model
is is certainly
based on the quality
of your data.
And in the experiment
scenario, you're
going to try out your model
with different data sets.
One of the ways you might manage
your data is based on dates
and partition your
data along with dates.
And you can use
those dates as a way
to generate a version in
your training program.
And as part of
producing a model,
you can also, alongside
the model, the saved model
that I was showing, also
output some metadata
about the data that was
used, in particular, things
like the date.
And at time of
deployment, you can
take those pieces of metadata
and produce a version number.
So, for example, if a model
was trained over the last seven
days, I can take
today's date as an input
into producing the version.
That's just one strategy.
You might have different labels
for your data set, for example,
like a production set versus
a experimental data set.
And you might actually have
names that you use your--
that you use to manage
your catalog of data.
And that would be
another piece of input
that you might use
in constructing
the version of your model.
ML Engine allows you to
deploy multiple models as well
as multiple versions per model.
So you can actually have, for
example, my taxifare model,
and I can be have v1.
I can have v2 and 3 and so on.
I can also have
something like latest.
I can declare one of them
as latest or default.
Or I can be explicit about
the version I want to go use.
So that's a sort
of overview of how
I might do versioning
and managing
the source of data that was used
to produce a particular version
of the model.
Moving on to the next question--
"Will training with ML
Engine show how long
training is estimated to take
so that I can estimate costs?"
It's actually quite
interesting and challenging
to offer an estimate of exactly
how long any particular job is
going to take,
because it largely
is a function of
your code in terms
of how complex the
TensorFlow graph is,
the kinds of operations
it uses, as well
as the data that you have.
There's a variety of
numbers that matter-- things
like the batch size, how much
data you read in every batch.
So the best way to
estimate a training job
is to run it, and in
the first few minutes,
look at the throughput and
see how many steps you're
progressing per second.
And you can use that
as a rough measure
to estimate how long it's going
to take for the entire job
to run through.
So that's probably the
best way to get a sense.
And you can tweak the
parameters and see
how they have a bearing
on your particular problem
and the costs associated
with that, correspondingly.
So next question-- "Is ML
Engine TensorFlow only?
I use sklearn"--
or scikit-learn.
"What can you do for Me ?"
So indeed, what I showed today
was ML Engine with TensorFlow.
And ML Engine v1 was
certainly around TensorFlow.
And this has been--
you can see a lot of
momentum around TensorFlow.
As Google open-sourced
TensorFlow,
it's quickly become one of
the most popular deep learning
frameworks.
And we've continued to
take advantage of that
and bring you all of
the power of TensorFlow,
whether it's accelerated
training, distributed training,
and shortly, TPUs as well.
However, we definitely
have heard from customers.
And we want to support a vast
and comprehensive toolbox
of ML capabilities.
And that includes
things like sklearn.
It includes things like
XGBoost, as well as
potentially any other framework
that you want to bring.
And so this is something that
I'd ask you to stay tuned for.
This is shortly forthcoming,
starting with on the prediction
side, where you can train a
model wherever you run training
today and bring it to Cloud
to put it into production.
And then we'll follow that
with training as well.
Moving right along.
"When can I get GPUs and
TPUs to train faster?"
So GPUs are available today.
I actually used it.
And I showed how you
can get started using it
with a simple
configuration that says,
use a GPU-enabled cluster.
We have both Akaze as
well as Pascal P100s.
You can also get not
just single-GPU training,
but you can also get two
and four for every worker.
And a lot of people
actually use a single node
with multiple GPUs to really
scale up their training.
TPUs are around the corner.
We have a product
called Cloud TPU,
which is the infrastructure as
a service offering with GCE.
And so you could
spin up a TPU node
and use that to
get TPU training.
With ML Engine,
you'll see, again,
a very managed experience, where
you can easily opt in into TPU,
just like I did for GPUs.
And ML engine will take
care of all of the resource
provisioning and managing
that through the lifecycle
of the training job.
We'd love to, of course,
hear your interests.
Please contact us
through the feedback link
that we have on our
Docs page in terms
of expressing your interest
to sign up for a TPU preview.
So moving to the next question--
"TensorFlow models seem complex.
Where do I start for my image
classification problem?"
So let me answer
that in two parts.
I will switch to my demo code.
So TensorFlow models can
be complex in the sense
that they allow you to do
new and interesting things
and use the full
power of TensorFlow.
However, if you're
doing basic things,
like a linear regression
model, TensorFlow
has a number of APIs that will
help you get started easily.
So I'm actually going to
show you on my screen--
go back and look
a little bit more
closely at this
particular piece of code.
So what I've gone ahead and
done is brought back my code
on screen.
And let me walk you through
a little bit more of the code
that I had for my
particular model.
So I'm going ahead and
importing TensorFlow,
which is, of course, the
standard TensorFlow package.
And here's the estimator API.
So the estimator API lives
under an estimator module.
And it has a number
of estimators.
DNN linear combined is
the one that I used.
There's DNN, there's
linear, and there's
more that are coming up.
And these provide a
simplified interface
to all of the power of
TensorFlow by a high-level API.
Once I've constructed
my estimator,
I also go ahead and
construct my data set.
So here, I'm
constructing a data set
that's a text line data set,
because I'm using CSV files.
And I can very
easily say, I would
like to repeat over that
data set for a given
number of epochs and read
that in a batched fashion
without actually
having to deal with all
of the low-level APIs in
TensorFlow that are there
and offer a lot of
power, but I don't
have to use them in
this particular case.
Once I've constructed
my estimator,
I can go ahead and construct
a training specification
with that data set.
I can go ahead and construct
an eval specification
and then simply go ahead
and call train and evaluate.
And so this gives
me a simple way
to get started with TensorFlow.
Now, the question was also
about image classification.
Now, image classification
is actually
quite interesting
in that there's
a technique called
transfer learning
that you might actually use.
And this is one of
the samples that is
available with Cloud Datalab.
If you were to go
get that, there's
some prebuilt samples
that cover that use case.
The idea with
transfer learning is
you take a image
model that's been
trained over a very large
number of general purpose
set of images.
And then you take that as a
starting point for your model
and fine-tune that
model with a smaller
set of more
domain-specific images
for your particular problem
and the particular set
of labels that you're trying
to classify those images over.
And so that gets you started
with not just prebuilt models
for TensorFlow, but also
pretrained models that
have been trained over
a very large data set.
So there's more questions
that have come in.
The question says, "The
deep part of the model
prepares the weight matrix
to be applied in prediction,
which is done by the wide."
So in reality,
what's happening is,
the model consists of-- the
model architecture consists
of two parts--
a wide part that is similar
to linear regression
and a deep part that's
similar to DNNs.
And both of these are
used at training time
as well as at prediction time.
It's the same graph
and the same set
of features that are being used
in both parts of the model.
And as the models--
as the ports of
the graph execute,
their outputs are combined to
produce the final regression
or classification.
It depends on the
model that you have.
So both are used at prediction.
So moving on.
"How do I pipeline
model inputs--
features and vectors--
and evaluate performance
and its accuracy in TensorFlow?"
So I'm assuming that
pipeline refers to--
I have a pipeline of--
a larger pipeline that goes from
my raw data to preprocessed.
So this is the part
that I would do
in one of the data
processing technologies
that Google Cloud has.
So this might be BigQuery.
Or it might be
something like Dataflow.
Or if you're
familiar with Spark,
you could use Cloud Dataproc.
And these data
processing tools would
allow you to take your
data, the raw data,
and convert those
into feature rectors.
Like I did, you would build both
training and evaluation sets
and use the evaluation set to
compute a set of predictions.
Once you have those
predictions, you
can now compare them
against the expected values
and get a sense of the
accuracy of the model.
"Since a model is as good"--
I think we've covered this one.
So if there's any
more questions,
please go ahead and get them in.
I'll put up these
links for people
to be able to visit
the product pages.
So thank you for tuning into
this live webinar from Google
Cloud.
Please stay tuned for our
next session, which is titled,
"Introduction to Google Cloud
Platform for G Suite Users,"
coming to you live
from New York City.
Thank you, and hope
you found this useful.
Goodbye.